معنا من تل ابيب مراسله الجزيره نجوان
سمري ونركز معك نجوان
على هذا الحرك السياسي هذا هذه النقاشات
بشان صفقه التبادل بشان مصير الحكومه لا
سما في ضوء ما نسب ل حزب المعسكر الرسمي
من ان هنالك الان شروط للبقاء في الحكومه
وايضا عوامل تجعل تجعل يجعل بني جانس
ينسحب من الحكومه وهي تتعلق اساسا بغزه
بصفقه التبادل وبغزل ما بعد
الحرب بالفعل هذا ما نقلته صحيفه هارت هذا
اليوم في مقال مطول جدا لاحد المحللين
السياسيين في الصحيفه يوسف فيرتر الذي نقل
عن مسؤولين في حزب المعسكر الرسمي بقياده
بيني جانز بانه هناك حاليا شرطان
لهذا الحزب من اجل البقاء في الحكومه او
على الاقل في حال لم يحدث امران فانهما قد
ينسحب من حكومه الطوارئ التي انضم اليها
بيني جانس وايزن كوت والوزراء من حزبهم مع
بدايه هذه الحرب بعد الاعلان عن تشكيل
حكومه طوارئ وكان بطبيعه الحال من احزاب
ال في حزب المعارضه اولا بانه في حال ايه
توصلا الى انطباع بان نتنياهو يرفض منحى
جدي لصفقه تبادل لل الاسرى الاعتبارات
سياسيه والقصد هنا بطبيعه الحال اعتبارات
سياسيه حزبيه تتعلق به وبمصير السياسي
فانهما فان هذا الحزب تحديدا
سينسحب من حكومه الطوارئ والنقطه الثانيه
انه في حال تم الاعلان عن فرض حكم عسكري
اسرائيلي في داخل غزه في ظل عدم
موافقه المجلس الوزاري الامني المصغر
بقياده ورئاسه نتنياهو بحث المرحله
الثانيه بعد الحرب اي فانه سيتم ايضا
سينسحب او سينسحب هذا الحزب من الحكومه
وعندما اقول سينسحب بالاساس بيني جانس
وغدي ايزنكوت دي ايزنكوت هو عضو مراقب في
مجلس الحرب ولكن كانت له تصريحات ربما اشد
في هذا السياق قبل ايام قليله في مقابله
مع قناه التلفزه الاسرائيليه الثانيه عش
وربما هو من يدفع ايضا بيني جانز بهذا
الاتجاه لتحديد هذه المواقف متى سيقرر
الحزب بانه لن يبقى غطاء لحكومه نتنيا
نتنياهو فيما يتعلق
بقضايا لها علاقه بالحرب على راسها بطبيعه
الحال صفقه التبادل جادي ايزن كوت يريد
ابرام صفقه التبادل حتى وان كان الثمن وقف
الحرب بشكل كلي وكان قد قالها بشكل علني
وصريح في مقابلات مع قناه التلفزه الثانيه
ع بان الجيش اخفق حتى الان وعلى مدار هذه
الاشهر خلال الحرب من من تحرير اي من
الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه وعليه حان الوقت
ان تعلن اسرائيل بانها اخفقت ضمن المساعي
العسكريه عن الافراج عن الاسرى وعليه يجب
التوجه فورا الى صفقه تبادل هذا ياتي ايضا
وسط البدء بتسريب بعض المعلومات عن جلسه
المجلس الوزاري الام المصغر الذي انعقدت
ايه التي انعقدت الليله الماضيه مباشره
بعد اجتماع لمجلس الح الحرب ووفقا لما تم
نشره قبل قليل في قناه التلفزه الثانيه ع
لكن بالتجديد على ان من نقل هذه الاخبار
هو احد الصحفيين اليمينيين المقرب جدا من
جهه من نتنياهو لكنه مقرب اكثر ربما من
الوزيرين سموتريتش وبين كفير تحديدا
سموتريتش وهو اي احد الوزراء في المجلس
الوزاري المصغر هذا الصحفي يقول بان نقلا
عن وزراء في هذا شاركوا في هذا الاجتماع
انه لم يتم عرض منحى لصفقه تبادل جديده من
اجل الاسرى وانه سيكون من المستحيل قبول
هدنه طويله اكثر من مده شهر وايضا سيتم
رفض الافراج عن اعداد كبيره من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين من دا داخل السجون بالاضافه
الى ذلك يقول بان انطباع الوزراء يقول بان
الصفقه ما زالت بعيده وربما قد تكون غير
قابله لان تخرج لحيز التنفيذ وان عدد كبير
من الوزراء عبروا عن تحفظهم ايضا من مده
الهدنه ومراحل تنفيذها وبالاساس مطالبتهم
بان يتم اشراكهم في اشراكهم في عمليه
المفاوضات وعدم فرضها عليهم كامر واقع
وهذا موقف
وبين كفير الذان اعلنا عنه في السابق
نشوان السبري من تلابيب شكرا جزيلا لك